you talk about the greats you have
you're Chris Martin Coldplay massively
successful so you get to have dinner
with the people that you grew up
listening to and I'm curious have you
gotten advice from those people you know
for whether it's a McCartney or a Bono
or anyone Michael Stipe any of those
people if I don't actually have dinner
anymore I stop eating at four and I
learned that from having lunch with
Bruce Springsteen
really that's really true yeah yeah what
happened you were having lunch with him
and he said after this no more
yeah you know and first of all Bruce is
in my equal top Pantheon of Heroes and
yeah and a wonderful guy and I love him
and I love Patty his wife and
and uh I was lucky enough to go over
there for lunch the day after we played
Philadelphia last year
I was on a really strict diet anyway
but I said Brewster's even more in shape
than me yeah and Patty so he's only
eating one meal a day so I was like well
there we go that's my next challenge did
you see what that meal was it's an eight
foot long
hey you want me all day and then you see
it's this giant vat of beef chili the
chef came out and said today we have
flank of buffalo with a steroid sauce
yeah well that's I mean I do this when
I've had the opportunity to sit with
people who were Heroes of mine
it's I find myself drifting out of my
body sometimes to look at the experience
from outside I get a little
self-conscious and I've learned to pull
myself back in and say just be with this
person yeah right now for sure and talk
to them but it's hard to do when you're
talking to a huge hero well I think for
two reasons one is we live in a culture
where we celebrate people yeah as much
as criticized and we also have our
celebrities and that and we're very much
ingrained to sort of think of them as
from another planet so if you didn't
grow up around that like you didn't or I
didn't yeah in some small part of you
think oh Tom Cruise comes from another
planet where everything's fine yeah of
course that's not true but
it's easy to fall back into that place
even when you're sitting with someone
for example with Tom Cruise who I love
his work so much the first time I met
him I didn't say anything about being a
fan because I was like he doesn't need
to hear this right and then I realized
no he's he's a human so next time I was
like I love Oblivion or whatever it was
so I have to do that thing as well it
doesn't have to be someone older it can
it could be
Adele or Harry Styles or who anyone that
I think is great sometimes I might drift
into that almost worshipful fan treating
them as a bit of an alien thing yeah but
then remember oh this is a this is a
person and might even be my friend I
love any moment where I get to see these
it doesn't happen often but if I get to
be around an icon and I just see that oh
yes they're dealing with the same stuff
in their life as I am that makes me very
very happy when I you know uh have that
experience and my my one with Bruce
Springsteen was a number of years ago
doing in a I did a charity event he was
the music I was the host slash comic
we both do it our thing and then we're
sitting at this table together after
we're done and Patty's with him and at
one point we're just talking about music
and I just is gonna lose me fans but I
inferred that
I don't quite Love The Grateful Dead as
much as other people do it's not quite
my thing Bruce I hope it doesn't get in
trouble again but Bruce was sort of was
like no I kind of I kind of know you
know some of it's great but then there's
some of it where I go quiet and then
Patty said
I love the Grateful Dead what are you
talking about and then I could just see
like anyone else who's with their
partner Bruce walking it back and Bruce
was going I did not mean to imply The
Grateful Dead and she was like well I
think they did amazing stuff how could
you say and I was saying again I would
like to State
I did not mean and I was just so
delighted that oh right when I put my
foot in it with my wife you know this is
what we deal with so Beyonce the other
day off to the Grammys and you know
um she's she's Beyonce she's my hero and
sister and everything but it's funny
because I'm like I have a knee problem
from stage and she'll say yeah me too
you know you have like the same work
complaints that no one else can talk
about exactly I breathe too much of this
and
that's yesterday the the strobes didn't
go off at the right time complaints to
anyone else in the world would just say
go yourself you know exactly no but
I love that it is eventually anything
that you do
day in and day out has elements of it
which it becomes a job and it is it's a
responsibility it's a responsible yeah
especially if you're entertaining lots
of people yeah you're hosting them you
remember on your show you know you feel
responsibility for I hope these people
have a great time yeah and if
something's going wrong and it's
compromising that great time or it's
compromising your ability to
it's really alarming